transat devra finalement voler de ses
propres ailes
l'entreprise devait être acheté par air
canada ottawa avait déjà donné son
accord
ne manquait plus que l'approbation de la
commission européenne
nous avons été informé cette semaine par
la commission européenne qu'elle
prévoyait de rendre un avis qui serait
négatif les deux transporteurs ont
préféré abandonner la transaction mais
il ne faut pas trop s'en étonner depuis
quelques mois le mariage semblait de
plus en plus incertain cette fusion là
n'avait plus la force ou l'intérêt que
ça représentait avant la pandémie
la kfw 19 a décimé l'industrie aérienne
en un peu plus d'un an l'offre d'air
canada pour acheter transat est passés
de 720 à 190 millions de dollars
l'homme d'affaires pierre karl péladeau
avait soumis une offre similaire
il est désormais un nouvel acheteur
potentiel l'offre est toujours valide
absolument la corde arrangements nous
empêcher d'avoir quelques conversations
ce soit avec monsieur péladeau ou avec
quelques autres qu'à quelques autres
acheteurs que ce soit à présent nous
sommes libres donc nous allons pouvoir
considérer considérer cette offre
les avions de l'entreprise québécoise
sont cloués au sol jusqu'à la mi juin
pour poursuivre ses activités tout seul
elle aura besoin d'un demi milliard de
dollars et elle compte sur l'aide
d'ottawa la parole du gouvernement
fédéral dans le transport aérien pour
moi aujourd'hui ça n'a aucune valeur
cet expert est sceptique ils comptent
davantage sur l'aide de québec en
février le premier ministre legault
cofondateur de transat s'était dit
préoccupé mais air transat une
entreprise très importante au québec et
que ce soit pierre karl péladeau ou
d'autres personnes qui sont intéressées
par le dos aussi
on suit ça de très près air transat sans
intervention aujourd'hui et ce à son
avenir est en danger mais elle pourrait
aussi être un joueur majeur quand les
voyages reprendront dans l'après
pandémie ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada morin